nous nous arrêtons à présent sur la
circulaire valse avec nous inviter le 28
novembre le ministre de l'intérieur a
publié une circulaire pour clarifier les
conditions dans lesquelles un étranger
en situation irrégulière pouvait obtenir
un titre de séjour le bilan un mois plus
tard avec le réseau éducation sans
frontières bonsoir odile johan vous êtes
membre de ce collectif qui milite contre
l'éloignement d'enfants étrangers
scolarisés en france causée par
l'éloignement de leurs parents étrangers
en situation irrégulière et puis
également sur ce plateau youssef bonsoir
vous êtes marocains en situation
régulière puisque vous êtes sans papiers
vous témoignerez tout à l'heure de votre
votre situation on va rentrer dans les
détails de cette circulaire avec vous et
vous allez nous expliquer quels sont les
points encore qui vous chagrine vous
n'êtes pas pleinement satisfaite
dans les grandes lignes déjà non disons
que selon les personnes
le point de vue est plutôt bon ou
mauvais car bien sûr ceux qui rentrent
dans les critères trouve que la
circulaire est bonne puisque pour eux
c'est la fin d'un cauchemar
mais tous les autres considèrent qu'elle
est mauvaise l'objectif c'était d'avoir
des critères clairs mais surtout
objectif est ce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui a dit qu'ils sont plus
objectifs du tout les critères sont
plaire au sens que ils sont écrits en
français qu'on peut les lire mais pas du
tout objectif puisque tout le temps il
ya des monsieur le préfet pourra s'il le
pense nécessaire qu'en plein de
conditionnel est plein de six donc pas
du tout clair et objectif est
complètement injuste par rapport à
beaucoup de cas on va parler après au
niveau national rsf a d'ailleurs publié
un communiqué toute fin novembre à
l'issue de la publication de la
circulaire de manuel valls qui précisait
c'est une régularisation de gribouille
vous partagez cet avis oh oui
puisqu'elle était précisé qu'elle
confortait l'image d'un gouvernement qui
sur tous les terrains du vote des
étrangers aux élections locales
également se refuse à la confrontation
idéologique avec la droite et l'extrême
droite ça c'était pour la précision le
drs fo au niveau national détaillons un
petit peu ce texte justement quels sont
les points qui aujourd'hui vous pose
problème véritablement dans cette
circulaire tu vas les grossièrement
parce que y'a la douce pas à jeun on
était donc comme vous l'avez expliqué on
s'occupe de tous les enfants des
familles et d'où les jeunes scolarisés
au lycée qu'ils ont leurs 18 ans
deviennent sans papiers alors pour les
premiers on verra tout à l'heure un cas
concret mais disons que notre chagrin
c'est le look est devenu un et cinq ans
de présence et trois ans de
scolarisation des familles
ça c'est ce qu'on demande c'est
aujourd'hui avec la news est ce qu'on
souhaite conseil on souhaiterait que
tout le monde soit régularisée bison ce
qu'on pensait qui aurait été possible
avec économie le gouvernement actuel
c'est cinq ans de présence ouf
trois ans collation c'est rare les cas
qui combine ces deux critères absolument
puisque très souvent les couples se sont
faits en france donc les parents ont
effectivement 50 présence mais où le
temps de se rencontrer de faire leurs
enfants et donc il faut attendre trois
ans de relation donc le cp dont beaucoup
plus que cinq ans de présence pour mme
inversement les enfants ont trois ans de
scolarité mais pas les 50 présence pour
les parents on continue à regarder cette
circulaire pour les salariés aussi la
circulaire articule des critères de
présence sur le sol français 3 à 7 ans
d'ancienneté dans le travail également
huit à trente mois et dans bausch
effective là pour les salariés pour les
salariés directement ça nous concerne
pas normalement mais dans les fêtes
beaucoup de parents pour vivre travail
et qu ici le conseil faisait mois s'ils
ne correspondent pas aux critères de
famille il pour moi de l'arize et pour
certains en tant que salarié le problème
c'est la crise et le chômage
ça veut dire que beaucoup il ya un an
aurait été régularisés et en chômage
sans forcément en tout cas sans emploi
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué c'est en
tout cas la fin des quotas avec cette
nouvelle circulaire et ça ça va déjà
dans le bon sens
c'est vraiment le point positif
doublement d'abord parce que ça veut
dire que pendant cinq ans normalement on
pourra quand on rentrera dans les
critères être régularisés ce qui
explique qu'à pas les grosses qu'eux et
les comme on aurait pu le craindre
et c'est aussi que
même si beaucoup de monde se présente on
est sûr que tous ceux qui sont les
critères qui sont médiocres mais ce qui
existe quand même seront régularisés
donc effectivement c'est le grand point
positif
j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde à présent sur
votre situation youssef justement quelle
est votre situation aujourd'hui vous
êtes sans papiers mais en situation
régulière vous ne pouvez pas prétendre
la régularisation dans le cadre de la
circulaire nous et pourquoi j'avais
votre situation aujourd'hui nous comme
il a dit mes enfants c'est la quatrième
année qui sont scolarisés mais je rentre
pas parce que j'ai rentré en france en
donc je n'avais pas 50 de présence je
rentre pas et quand vous avez une carte
européenne il connut surentraînement
donnait déjà un récépissé et du chrome
os est déjà travail quand il travaillait
à l'aéroport de milan
je rentrais delhi paris j'ai trouvé que
ce que vous avez travaillé en tout début
en italie sion pour un petit peu votre
parcours vous disiez vous avez une carte
de résident européens auront d'ailleurs
c'est par l'italie aura une durée
illimitée avec eux
commune et enfin circuler dans toute
l'europe comme j'ai rentré en france et
mondial on ne peut pas pour travailler
parce qu'ils avaient une famille suis
rentré sur mon pour les enfants parce
que quand un mec te moques moi et ma
femme on a dit syndicale qui prend la
culture française il doit aider le
primaire ils ont commencé dans des
établissements qui sont agréés par le
centre qui tient la française là bas au
maroc qu on a rentré bon j'ai dit il
faut qu'elle rentre on prend ça comme
j'avais deux belles-soeurs donc et qui
m'ont aidé à aller fait rentrer ici
après il a fait une demande à la
préfecture j'ai demandé le respect c'est
après le récépissé avec le travail ça se
travaille
et comme j'avais mes diplômes c'est ça
les reports j'ai travaillé à
charles-de-gaulle à roissy après un
certain moment j'ai reçu une lettre de
la préfecture a demandé il faut que je
rentre à mort comme ça après deux ans de
dissiper ces deux ans tous les trois
mois j'avais un récépissé
après je réussis à l'être moi et ma
femme et mes enfants qu'il faut qu'on
rentre au maroc avec une carte européen
je sais pas là aujourd'hui
votre femme réside en france oui aux
enfants également vous avez reçu une
oqtf une obligation à quitter le
territoire français oui ça fait un an
maintenant et je peux pas montrer mes
enfants ils sont déjà scolarisés j'avais
même une carte européen quand j'ai
contacté un avocat les associations
maintenant j'ai porté plainte contre la
prévert des versets on entend maintenant
jugement est-ce que vous avez
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
français c'est pas le cas pour le reste
de votre famille non moi et ma femme a
pour vos enfants qui y sont scolarisés
ils sont nombreux dans ce cas comme
youssef par exemple dans le département
des yvelines pour qu'il vous intervenez
absolument malheureusement est en donc
malheureusement on en connaît peu donc
parce qu'ils se manifestent pas tous il
se cache et on vous remercie d'être venu
témoigner sur ce plateau ce soir
absolument ils se cachent ils sont ils
sont nombreux au que pouvez vous faire
pour eux et que faites vous on leur
explique que plus il se montre la preuve
youssef est présent aujourd'hui prison
de chances d'être régularisés ça veut
dire d'être en situation régulière 1
comme le souhaitent tous parce que tous
travaillent donc certain travail il est
venu en france avec la fin un projet il
a commencé en italie vous travaillé
ensuite les est venu vous installer en
france avec un ami j'ai véritablement
été fait dans les oblige puisqu'il ne
veut pas ils ne veulent jamais disons
vivre aux crochets de la france donc on
les oblige à travailler de manière
illégale ou travail au noir
il ne s'est pas leur choix c'est leur
nécessité
zurich et s'il était régularisée ils
cotiseraient dans les caisses
donc tout le monde y aurait intérêt et
certains travaillent des fausses cartes
les cartes du goût du cousin donc eu
cotisent mais n'en profite pas ils n'ont
pas la fibre sociale
ils n'ont pas le droit à l'apl disons
qu'ils ont tous des conditions très
difficiles et on leur impose tous à
travailler dans des conditions illégales
vous travaillez actuellement on ne
travaillait pas actuellement je
travaille pas parce que je trouvais de
la famille et c'est là parce que vous
avez au moins deux belles-soeurs
l'étendue de ma femme tout ça c'est pour
cela mais je suis dans une situation
difficile ou émises enfants parce que
les gens ils peuvent t'aider mais ne la
jav est un garçon qui à l'âge de
l'adolescence puisque saison et est c
est le temps des choses mais comme je
travaille pas vraiment j'avais de la
peine une fois de plus merci d'être venu
témoigner sur ce plateau réseau
éducation sans frontières qui était
invité ce soir à réagir un mois après la
mise en place de la circulaire valse de
la réalité du terrain des difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent encore certain par
rapport aux critères qui ont été
dorénavant modifié merci donc à vous
d'être venu bientôt la fin de cette
édition le rappel des titres à présent
de ce soir
la sécurité routière à quelques jours
des fêtes de fin d'année l'heure est à
la prévention notamment à l'intention
des plus jeunes
la cible la lutte contre les excès dus à
l'alcool
l'école de la deuxième chance de trappes
va faire rentrer son 100ème jeunes cette
année l'établissement qui accueille des
jeunes sortis du milieu scolaire affiche
des résultats encourageants à l'issue de
leur formation 70 % d'entre eux trouvent
une solution est les anciennes cabines
téléphoniques ont une deuxième vie elles
vont être recyclés en bibliothèque de
rue un projet original nous développer
notamment et par la maison de l'europe
vous le voyez sur ces images nous en
parlions ce soir avec nos invités un
projet qui est développée notamment en
partenariat avec l'opérateur
téléphonique orange et puis il n'y a pas
d'âge pour commencer le basket une
initiation au baby basket a été proposé
à guyancourt 112 jeunes issus de
quatorze clubs du département pour y
participer
la sécurité routière a donc distribution
d'éthylotests sont organisées
régulièrement on le sait l'obligation
d'en posséder un dans son automobile
sera peut être remise en cause c'est
l'objet de discussions actuellement pour
autant ces éthylotests peuvent se
montrer très utile en période de fin
d'année après des repas peut être un peu
trop arrosé les fêtes de fin d'année
approchent et il ne faudrait pas que
festivités rime avec accident pour
alerter sur les dangers de l'alcool au
volant des bénévoles de la prévention
routière ont distribué samedi des
éthylotests dans un centre commercial du
chesnay il est toujours obligatoire d'en
disposer dans les voitures la cible les
jeunes les jeunes c'est une majorité de
d'accidents sont dus à l'alcool
évidemment c'est un peu notre problème
des 18 27 ans
la catégorie d'ajouter il nous apporte
j'aime beaucoup le slogan éclatez vous
mais pas sur la route c'est tout à fait
de circonstance pour les fêtes en 2011
dans les yvelines sur les 45 accidents
mortels survenus 15 étaient liés à
l'alcool
depuis 2006 l'alcool est la première
cause de mortalité sur les routes devant
la vitesse chaque semaine près de 76
personnes meurent sur les routes de
france et parmi elles près de 23 paires
de la vie dans un accident lié à un abus
d'alcool
quelques informations pour finir cette
édition politique le front national
prépare déjà les municipales en tout cas
à versailles bruno gollnisch rencontrera
ce vendredi les militants bruno
gollnisch ancien candidat à la
présidence de ce parti face à marine le
pen le front national qui a déjà lancé
la campagne du scrutin qui se déroulera
en mars 2014 dans plusieurs communes en
france et du mans à marseille en passant
par avion et puis politique toujours
l'accord fillon-copé la fin du
feuilleton est intervenu hier soir on
retiendra qu'une nouvelle élection doit
se tenir d'ici à l'automne 2013 que les
statuts aussi sont appelés à évoluer
par exemple le président de l'ump tous
membres de l'équipe dirigeante s'ils
sont candidats à cette élection devront
se placer en réserve dès le début de la
campagne électorale s'il n'avait pas
forcément été le cas cette fois ci
quant à valérie pécresse que vous avez
aperçu sur ces images la numéro 2 de
l'équipe de françois fillon elle
deviendra secrétaire général délégué et
ce dès le mois de janvier une prise de
fonction qui marquera la réunification
des deux groupes ump à l'assemblée
une toute dernière information et cette
colère des élus de droite en ce qui
concerne le métro du grand paris dans un
rapport dit aux années remis à la
ministre cécile duflot il est préconisé
de repousser à 2030 la création du grand
métro notamment dans les yvelines
le président ump du conseil général
alain schmitz est monté au créneau pour
dénoncer une mission de dupes ce site
ait parlé d'une grande déception de son
côté valérie pécresse toujours
conseillère régionale et chef de file de
l'ump dans le département a demandé à
être reçus par la ministre de l'égalité
des territoires je vous retrouve
mercredi dès 18 heures en direct pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 une édition
spécial fêtes de fin d'année spécial
noël c'est de saison émission qui sera
aussi rediffusé 19h 22h30 et minuit
comme chaque soir de la semaine
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée à
demain